hey Nick where you hiding where you
hiding Nick all right I'll find you you
know it's not oh hey your shotgun though
and if you're such a scrub your absolute
piece of trash okay how did you find me
[Music]
oh geez new maps savage the southeastern
Asia map was out on test servers as of
last night I've played a little bit but
you and Jacob both played a lot more
than me what do you think of it so far I
think there's two ways you can play this
map
I think the first way you can play this
map is you go to one of the hot beds
there's the temple area and there's a
resort area obviously those two are not
finished yet so they're kind of these
weird race game checkerboarding like
waiting for textures it's pretty cool
because I can see the weapons easier
there and it seems like that's like this
school here on this map and so if you go
to those two hot beds you're gonna get
in a gunfight right away there seems
like the loot is better there's a lot of
scars a lot of em fors lying around
there
and it's generally pretty fun you go
down there you might get two or three
kills if you're one of the ones who can
survive it then that's awesome but if
not like at least you dropped in and had
a good time and you get right back into
another one and then the other way to
play it is what you were kind of talking
about Jake where it's more the long and
methodical route again like some of the
other ones where I like to sometimes
land out in the middle by bonyen Grove
or maybe the coconut groves and stuff
like that and in those areas I can like
take my time loop slowly that's
necessarily saying that is a way to play
I'm saying no matter where you land if
you survive if you're that last one
you're gonna hear in a hotbed you're
still gonna have a really slow middle of
the match you're gonna have to wait
until it gets the circle strengths but
they did try to counter that I didn't
notice the circles closing quicker
especially near the end like I remember
being pushed forward faster than I have
and other ones but yeah I think is good
if you look at the map you see like the
actual web of roads there's like a
settlement of buildings almost at every
single intersection miramar obviously
had those hills and there wasn't a lot
of foliage to take place like in Miramar
few work on the open you would have to
use like a lot of zigzagging to not die
whereas you know og map you could go
down in like wheat fields or whatever
but when you left a building and like
you would plant a team to run
like okay we're gonna go to red which is
at North like 655 you know there's gonna
be like maybe 45 seconds of running
where you could get shot in this it's
like okay I'm gonna leave this building
ten seconds to the next settlement but
in that 10 seconds it's gonna be even
more intense and I think that for all
presumably is what pop G Corp was going
for with this map they were trying to do
something that you could like take
almost bite-sized pubsey experiences get
in get out obviously for tonight is its
main competitor especially considering
they released savage you know who knows
how many months it's out it's not gonna
be one month like Miramar wasn't it's
nowhere near that close to being done
but I wonder if they release it this
early specifically to like almost remind
people hey puppies still here and we're
bringing out new stuff don't worry might
not be out for another three months but
you can check it out now and give us
feedback and I don't know did you feel
like that's what they're doing like
trying to provide this bite-size
experience I can stay relevant I think
so but I also think that it could have
been even more bite-size I think it
could have been smaller I think they
could have gotten rid of one of those
islands yeah but I do feel like it is
comparable now to fortnight size because
when I jump out of the battle bus when
I'm playing fortnight I do feel as if I
can like I can get to like different
areas of the the map pretty easily from
where I jump out and that's not really
possible sometimes with like regular pub
G where I'm like oh man I got a long
jump this or maybe if I land really
quick and grab a car and then I Drive
out to the military base on Miramar like
in this situation I can generally jump
towards the center of the map and kind
of reach anywhere I want to go with this
first couple circles right it's within
those first couple circles and that
feels really really good where it's like
okay this is definitely smaller but I
agree there's still some down periods
where you're like they're like okay I
haven't seen anyone a little while like
let me keep pushing and maybe I go like
somewhere where there might be like a
hotbed for more players and things like
that but it does feel comparable to
fortnight's so if that is in fact what
they were going for I think it sounds
like they're having right there
I mean I think part of the reason to
they released it so early people test is
like they don't know if it works they
don't know if this is what people want
with pub G do people want these shorter
matches I don't know the way they're
sharing it is interesting because it's
not through the test server you have to
get a code from them and I think if you
bought the game you can redeem it you're
too late now but you can redeem a code
and you're in a separate game almost
where you can test out this map it kind
of makes me think like I wonder if if
this doesn't work if people don't like
it I won't I'm curious if it will still
actually be pushed to the final game or
if it'll just kind of be like thrown
behind them you know they'll like save
it for later maybe look back at it later
because they still have another map in
the works - yeah like that yeah all in
all like do you think this is actually a
really smart move a good direction for
pubs you to take wave like one other
maps you still have OGG all the time
which is still my favorite and maybe
it's just a nostalgia or I think that it
captures the whole like chess aspect
like don't want to pick up these items
and that set them over there or is the
circle gonna close in or should I worry
about the circle now I feel like Savage
is the map that you want to play if
you're getting used to the game like
shooting I feel like you're gonna have
more encounters you can practice way
more it's like everybody dropped into
the school to get like better at the
game right like the star just fighting
right away
I feel like savage might be a better
practice realm for people just getting
into the game you have you throw some
bots in there yeah yeah this is this map
gonna come to mobile who knows like I
don't know like what their road map is
as far as if they're gonna release it
are they really so let's say that stuff
at the same time on mobile and I hope
not let's get let's get xbox some love
but in general I think this is a smart
move for pub G if they like want to just
keep reminding people hey we're here
we're still a fantastic game to say the
least not that they need to remind a lot
of people but there are a lot of people
playing for tonight it's this phenomenon
and now like I think pub G if they want
to go in a direction with one of maps I
think this is a smart direction to go in
and I'm excited play more of it yeah I
taper it off I've been played in well
but I've been playing this map and I'm
like alright I think I'm ready I'm ready
to go back in that's what I needed
ready go play now
too much to do let's do it some of us
work during the day Nick
[Music]